all right let's talk bitcoin
cryptocurrencies uh you and i had some
epic showdowns on television you called
it everything from crypto garbage uh to
one time you forbid me from owning any
more of it uh
but i think that there's a lot of
changes that have happened in the market
both from a regulatory standpoint and
also some of the market dynamics and you
now are comfortable starting to allocate
to it so maybe walk us through um kind
of what changed and then how you're
thinking about allocating to a bitcoin
of cryptocurrencies today
yeah so what changed is exactly what you
said paul the regulatory environment i
work in a very regulated world i'm an
investor in so many different financial
services companies that are reporting
issuers and so we don't have the luxury
of being offside with regulators not now
not ever and in 2017 when we were
talking about those epic moments and
it's true because i get those things
shoved in my face every day but but i
point out that when things change i
change
that's when i took my first bitcoin at
ethereum positions in 2017. obviously
i've done very well with those but
recently after the regulators in
switzerland france germany australia
england japan canada all started to
change their stance on crypto it allowed
me to start to allocate to it in a
compliant way
and that's really what got me going
obviously this is an asset class that's
here to stay it's still going through a
very nascent phase i'll be putting a lot
more into it as time changes and still
the regulator's not 100 on board we all
know that but things are getting better
not just domestically but
internationally and so i'm an
international investor and in many
countries where we're talking about
bitcoin or ethereum or other
assets other other crypto assets tokens
and coins uh the regulators opened up
what's the current allocation percentage
i think at one point we talked and you
said you were at three percent are you
still at three
no i've i'm
you know i've told everybody i've
disclosed that by the end of the year
i'll probably be at seven percent that's
the target because i've gone beyond
ethereum and and bitcoin i have a pretty
big position in usd right now usdc i'm
moving into some other assets that i'm
negotiating right now i have been
struggling with this esg issue around uh
mining my own coin as you recall that
topic was really forefront at bitcoin
2021 when i moderated and i think you
were there the the major miners and how
they're trying to deal with this carbon
offset issue i still get people asking
about that i still have i still have uh
sovereign funds that i serviced in some
of my other companies asking what are
you going to do
around the csg because they have these
compliance committees and i know a lot
of people debate this issue but it's not
going away
and so i think you're going to see a
real move towards places like west texas
uh
solar
wind ideas around new gen generation
where it's completely compliant
hybrid as i'm a shareholder in there now
jamie leverton does uh sustainable
mining with flare gas so i mean there's
there's ways to get around it pomp um
and i'm using that to increase my
allocation but i think by the end of the
year across all crypto assets it'll be a
seven percent weighty and it could go as
high as 20 if i wanted to but i'm just
taking it one step at a time what would
it need to take or what would have to
happen for you to go from the seven
percent target today to 20
performance performance i mean that's
basically you know i'm not a cowboy here
i'm actually allocating capital towards
achieving a distributable return between
six and eight percent a year and so you
know we have a lot of volatility
in bitcoin and right now we're kind of
61 back from the lows and that's great
but not every crypto asset has to be
that volatile so when you start to build
out your portfolio let's go to usdc
um you know
you you actually can take that as a
relatively stable asset and write
contracts on it for 60 days 30 days 90
days and generate three and a half four
percent yield which is what i'm doing
right now and so i look at it as a
portfolio approach some of these things
have volatility some don't but you know
the biggest problem which is
holding all of us back in the crypto
industry right now
is compliance at the institutional level
you know you go in and you say look um
everybody's talking about this all right
i'm running let's say i'm running a
billion dollar mandate that's not
uncommon and i want to put 10 into
crypto
you have to be able to find a platform
that can link to your internal reporting
and your external regulatory you know
it's not like i got a hundred if i'm
pulling a 10 allocation on a billion
that's 100 million i'm not going to
download an app on my phone and put 100
billion 100 million dollars into it i'm
going to have to have an institutional
compliant platform and the industry's
not there yet paul it's got a lot of
work to do on that front and the more we
move towards that the more capitalism
will be coming in hey guys thanks so
much for watching that clip of the best
business show make sure you like and
subscribe to the channel turn on
notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it